[Musique]
déjà un point de situation sur les
agriculteurs ça évolue ce soir oui alors
ce matin encore la 13 et la 10 était
inaccessible un cortège de tracteurs
s'est déplacé en fin de matinée sur la
National 12 au niveau de mé les
agriculteurs ont bloqué les deux cens de
circulation province- Paris et
Paris-province vous avez suivi dans la
journée le Premier ministre Gabriel
hatal a prononcé un discours en début
d'après-midi il a annoncé plusieurs
mesure pour répondre aux exploitants
agricoles notamment un soutien fiscal et
social de 150 millions d'euros pour les
éleveurs l'arrêt des importation de
fruits et légumes cultivés avec le
pesticide cclpride pour éviter la
concurrence déloyale ou une augmentation
massif de contrôle des industriels et
des supermarchés la FDSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs appellent toujours à pardon
Appell à suspendre tous les blocage mais
à pone la situation reste pour le moment
inchangée la route est toujours bloquée
au moment où je vous parle on suit bien
sûr cette situation avec attention alors
la colère a aussi grondé du côté des
enseignants aujourd'hui oui les
professeurs de maternelle du primaire et
du secondaire se sont mobilisés
aujourd'hui avec ce rassemblement lancé
par les syndicats ils voudraiit obtenir
une augmentation salariale de meilleures
conditions de travail et dénonce le
manque de moyens et de remplacement il
protestait également contre la réforme
du choc des savoirs instauré par Gabriel
hatal ancien ministre de l'Éducation et
actuel Premier ministre dès la rentrée
2024 il prévoit la création de groupes
de niveau en mathématique et en français
pour les élèves du 6e et du 5e pour le
personnel enseignant cette réforme
risque d'avoir de graves conséquences au
collège Alexandre Duma à morpa
aujourd'hui 80 % des enseignants étaient
mobilisés selon le syndicat
départemental SNES on écoute les propos
recueillis au micro de Clara de Frutos
idéologiquement on y est pas du tout
pour nous l'école elle sert pas à trier
socialement les élèves elle est là pour
permettre à tous les élèves de réussir
dans de bonnes conditions on n pas de
texte réglementaire on n pas de décret
donc on doit appliquer une réforme sans
s'appuyer sur ni des moyens ni des
textes donc on est complètement
désemparé c'est une catastrophe pour
nous sans compter ensuite les
dégradations de conditions de travail
que ça entraîne en cascade suite à cette
réforme on va devoir faire des
alignements
pédagogiques une progression commune
mathématique une progression commune en
français ce qui va nous restreindre
notre pédagogie et notre liberté
pédagogique à force de cout de nouvelles
réforme à force de décret les
professeurs sont fatigués épuisés et on
commence à en avoir marre de tout ça et
des parents d'élèves aussi ét présent ce
matin pour soutenir les professeurs en
grève on est là de toute façon pour les
enseignants qui sont de qualité et pour
surtout nos enfants quel est l'avenir de
nos enfants en fait qui vont arriver là
dans dans les dans les prochaines années
finalement donc c'est aussi surtout pour
ça qu'on est là aujourd'hui et des
chiffres qui nous sont parvenus il y a
peu par l'Académie de versaill sur la
mobilisation des enseignants aujourd'hui
selon l'académie de versaill 35 % des
enseignants étaient mobilisés dans les
collèges un peu plus de 13 % chez les
enseignants des lycées général et
technologiques et environ 18 % un peu
moins même de 19 % chez les professeurs
de primaire autre actualité Gabriel
c'était il y a 70 ans l'abbé Pierre
lançait un appel oui un appel à l'aide
on peut même dire prononcé il y a 70 ans
vous l'avez dit et qui raisonne toujours
aujourd'hui le voici mes amis au secours
une femme vient de mourir gelé cette
nuit à 3h sur le trottoir du boulevard
Sébastopol ce message d'indignation
reste encore d'actualité en 2023 ce sont
330000 personnes qui dorment dans la rue
contre 143000 en 2012 en France selon le
rapport de la fondation abépierre de
2024 à cette occasion le centre Emmaus
de Bou gival organise du 1er au 3
février des expositions et des
projections pour partager l'histoire de
l'homme d'église qui était la BA pierre
une information qui va intéresser les
jeunes qui s'interrogent sur leur avenir
comme chaque année gu en cours aide les
étudiants dans leur orientation oui le
forum de la voie professionnelle ouvrira
ses portes demain dès 9h jusqu'à 19h au
Pavillon Pierre valdec Rousseau un large
choix de métiers et de formation sera
représenté dans le secteur du bâtiment
de la santé de la défense du transport
ou encore de l'hôtellerie ce forum il
s'adresse particulièrement aux
collégiens qui souhaitent se diriger
vers une finière professionnelle et vous
terminez ces informations du jour avec
une websérie oui Grégori elle s'appelle
démo c'est le nom de cette série mais
c'est aussi l'abréviation du dispositif
d'éducation musicale et orchestrale à
vocation sociale c'est un projet qui
mêle social et démocratisation culturel
90 enfants qui habitent sur le
territoire cinquantinois dans des
quartiers qui qui élèv de la politique
de la ville sont concernés leur aventure
a commencé en 2022 lorsqu'ils ont
rejoint l'orchestre elle se terminera en
2025 avec le concert de fin de cycle
alors la websérie vous permet de suivre
leur progression et leur évolution deux
épisodes sont déjà en ligne sur la
chaîne Youtube de C an eneline merci
Gabriel et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir dans les ivel n'hésitez pas à la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news